monkeys or whatever and then the chinks
and all that stuff
how difficult would that be to i think
you're just [ __ ] pitching a movie dog
me and you
karate we karate them we're like yeah
karate them it's called karate though
like we [ __ ] them up
i like that i'm chris tucker you're
[ __ ] jackie chan i like that movie
what are you calling it karate though
karate them karate
we [ __ ] karate them dude we go
through the whole hospital [ __ ] them
up yeah yeah very japanese that is
i like that premise me you me you and
chris stefano is he in it no no i have
to
know that because i know his tv show's
not going to be you kevin hart
me you kevin hart right yeah and put
gabriel glaciers on it
we're all nurses yeah a [ __ ] kkk guy
is our you know our patient right and he
spouts out all kinds of [ __ ]
i think there's a premise there
absolutely right maybe at the end we
forgive him
i know what you did there i know what
you did there okay i pitched a great
movie a buddy cop movie yeah
but you looked at me and you said it
doesn't have enough star power
then you proceeded to say kevin hart and
you just pulled up you you said okay
johnny's the guy with the idea because i
can't sell it yeah i can't
kill him
you would have left history hyenas too
oh i did do that i i apologize yeah you
didn't do that oh my god even though you
know i'm the guy
right and you know me and you would
you're lucky you're still in the [ __ ]
movie
i'm like i'm still in this room i know i
was in my head i'm like you know what
we've got to keep him and we'll give him
a couple lines
yeah let's bring in kevin and gabriel
dude he totally [ __ ] hijacked my [ __ ]
you could go
sell it and you'd be like you like dude
i'll give you to pay you off yeah i'll
give you a producer driver
no i want to be in it man i want to
fight for this like fly stallone did for
rocky
but you have to still read for it come
on it's my idea you can't just give your
body
you can't take it you can't replace me
with gabriel young glaciers that's
[ __ ] up you know what here's what
we'll do
here's what we'll do you replace me with
allie wong no no
no it'll sell bill here's what we'll do
okay
you and i will write it yeah both
producers yeah
i'll give you co-lead thank you okay i'm
gonna get ep credit because this was
really my
idea talking about my sister right
you'll make you will make you love
interest
but no i wanna ep and that's it i don't
wanna be on screen but we will
you'll have some sort of disability in
the movie okay i like it i'm listening
where
you don't have to talk that much okay as
long as it's like you have a stutter
right and then we always cut you off
yeah
shut up johnny right yeah yeah yeah i
like it
or when we finish or yeah or we finish
your sentences i like that yeah okay
as long as it's explained don't call
them that yeah
yeah yeah like if the raw it'd be a good
scene a funny scene if the bad guy's
coming i could
tell i can't say it yeah and then he
comes but then you [ __ ] karate it you
turn around
let me ask you something yeah something
right now man
let me ask you something the movie's
called karate and i want
no you're the lead there's no karate in
there man i have about so if there's no
karate how are you gonna [ __ ] kill
the bad guys
poison poisoning
dude we're trying to sell this in asia
you've already taken an oath
no because the movie is this right we
think about killing him right
but then he's drugged out right and he
starts popping out that
there's some treasure or something he
buried some group
with some money right so then we're like
we can't kill him because of the fact
that we want us
he he's talking about something that we
can get right right so our whole goal is
to get it out of him
right right and then it becomes a road
movie
we he we break him out who plays that
guy who's the racist guy
oh god that's so many good people yeah
we can get who uh
um for fox michael rappaport michael
rapper
play great perfect krista
he is out i'm trying he's out i'm trying
to get him in with you yeah i don't want
you to cancel out you know what
that'd be nice yeah oh here's what it is
okay
here's what the movie is right okay we
have a guy kkk guy right older guy
he starts popping off that at the
compound we they had buried
give me a golden you know nazi
you know artifact sure that's worth a
lot of money okay right
and so uh there's dick
the mold of hitler's dick yeah and how
much gold it's like the head of it is a
diamond piece
right and the you know it's like this
you know um
jade the nutsack is jay oh wow you're
jay's though precious
yeah precious stones yes you know it's a
uh faber jay
pepper j made it yeah you know what i
mean in the in the mid 1900s no the
balls are faberge eggs what ball he had
one ball
he had one ball
yes and inside it was like a a golden
swastika
right wow or the secret on how to get
rid of all the jute
we gotta go that was
maybe we have to get it to destroy it
because the germans chris stefano
christopher was trying to get it to get
rid of the jews we're the good guys
we're the good guys so we're trying to
get to the secret to kill all the jews
and destroy it
so this is this golden uh artifact
solid gold yeah one sack is
a faberge egg that we open then there's
a message in there
right that we're trying to get to to
destroy right just destroy
we also want to sell the object too
we'll go to pawn stars we got to make a
couple dollars yeah yeah
yeah because that will be the sequel we
want to destroy but then we make money
and then there'll be a sequel because
it's still out there so
christopher stefano plays the the no the
the hitler youth the hitler youth that
that runs the comp
right because it kind of looks like that
it does i want to pitch a backstory
about how your tongue got cut off
okay because you're not speaking a lot
in this whole thing right oh yeah i
thought it was just going to be summer i
swore from bobby but
i'm gonna i'm gonna okay what's up
what's up this is we're gonna do
rewrites on this when we do it right and
you're gonna be a part of it right i
want to hear
any asian el nino i just want to say
this this is what this discussion you
want
you and i have on the side because he's
a writer he's a director
listen i know that giannis is throwing
out these notes and his some of his
ideas
that have a lot to do with asia he wants
me to wear a ninja outfit
right as a nurse which is ridiculous
you're the only nurse wearing
right right and you know he he has this
like samurai outfit that you know when
we go to the
or whatever but just you know shoot him
down when he brings you got to shoot
those down
yeah shoot those down okay so you work
in a laundromat
i thought i was a nurse with you at the
hospital okay
but also your parents own a laundry mat
that okay all right yeah
yeah that's it yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
shoot it down yeah that's very good i'm
just throwing it out there so what's the
sequel
uh so the sequel will be you're right we
pawn it everyone thinks we're the heroes
but then at the end we go
but wait a second do we really like the
jews and we're unsure
so we say let's make some money off this
thing interesting
interesting we pawn it that way this
thing is still in the world and part two
that's when i grow my tongue back i can
talk i can get more lines i make more
money on the second sequel
no and we karate we do karate after
poison this is it okay okay
so we go and find the thing right we
destroyed this stefano
right we finally have the thing when we
at the end of the movie can i destroy it
yeah of course
you're gonna let me oh yeah can you
write that in there's a torch scene just
like yeah okay thanks
yeah and so and we we do meisner [ __ ] so
it's gonna be real okay good
and so um i open up the egg right yeah
we open it up right and in it is not
the way to destroy the jews in it is the
formula to make a time machine to go
back to
nazi germany to go back in time and to
be the schindlers
right and we're the schindlers whoa
right so us for
me you gabriel iglesias right yeah i
guess you could be in the movie too come
on i'm
gonna put my tongue out with a samurai
sword yeah right you're not gonna say
much anyway yeah right
and so me you kevin hart and gabriel we
go back in time
yeah to nazi germany and we tried to
destroy hitler
yeah in the regime wow what do you think
who plays hitler
ali oh that ally wong maybe yeah yeah
it's got to be
accurate yes it's got to be someone
ethnic though
right because that's the time we live in
that's the time we live and that's why
allie would play it ally would be hitler
and she can be her personality can be a
little hitler-ish yeah
okay so ally we'll have to cast it we'll
have to do auditions as well
yeah we'll cast it yeah we'll cast but
we need a star you can't just throw
another me in there
let's go bigger yeah let's go i'll go
bigger than um
matt damon meryl streep meryl streep
that's nailed it yeah
well he nailed it imagine mel streep as
hitler
nailed it so good it's so good right
already an oscar and that's something
that you could google that no one's ever
googled mill street best hitler
i just thought of another one yeah dude
yanny's cavs
yeah meryl streep as hitler was never
been googled in never never can you
please i mean if
i there there's no way that's been good
yo you're gonna wait no no
she's gonna try it's gonna be because
republicans call her hitler sometimes
right
oh yeah oh there is like a there's a
real street and hitler in one photo yeah
how about
i think a better more believable hitler
is tilda swinton
oh yeah that's just good acting yeah
tilda swinton is hitler that's a great
suggestion that's a great suggestion
um who's going to play schindler
but this is before he does the list oh
do we offer it to joe rogan so he can
turn it down because we know he will
yeah oh yeah well yeah because we have
to offer just as a respect just respect
yeah yeah yeah he'll turn it down let me
just say this though um
okay he can play my part we've never had
you solo right
right we're going to have you back again
we i really enjoyed it i enjoyed this
yeah i could talk forever it was fun
yeah this has been amazing
and if i lived in new york can you come
on my podcast not only that would i do
that yeah
if i lived in new york yeah i would
start one with you and i wouldn't [ __ ]
you
that's like somebody else nice i think
you and i would have